President Trump claims serious trade
talks with China are on the way as he
finishes the g7 summit in France in a
meeting with Egypt's president mr. Trump
said Chinese leaders called him to say
they want to negotiate after he
threatened even higher US tariffs on
more than 500 billion dollars in Chinese
goods now the president's statement made
Wall Street stock futures jump China's
foreign ministry spokesman said this
morning he has not heard about those
phone calls that the president mentioned
but mr. Trump says there has been
communication at the highest level
meanwhile the latest CBS News poll finds
a majority of Americans believe
President Trump is responsible for the
current state of the economy 42% say his
policies impact the economy a great deal
and only 8% say his policies impact the
economy not at all Paula Reid is at the
g7 summit traveling with the president
Paula China is not in the g7 but seems
to loom large there why absolutely Tony
President Trump is under enormous
pressure to show that his tough-talking
trade strategy is working but several of
the other g7 leaders have used their
meetings with the president here in
France to express their concerns about
his approach president Trump tried to
put a positive spin on his escalating
trade war with China amid concerns from
other world leaders that his approach is
hurting the global economy but the White
House has been saying for weeks that
China wants a deal but it's unclear if
there's actually been any movement
China's foreign minister had a sobering
take saying only that China hopes the
u.s. can come back to a path of
rationality understand on Friday the
u.s. announced it would increase
existing tariffs on China after it added
retaliatory tariffs on 75 billion
dollars worth of US imports sending
stock markets into turmoil China was
going to overtake us the tension between
the world's two largest economies has
haunted the president throughout a
summit that he hoped would project
strength back at home other world
leaders have expressed concern about his
approach at one point even the president
appeared to have misgivings the White
House insisted the remarks were greatly
misinterpreted but even one of mr.
Trump's closest allies Britain's new
prime minister Boris Johnson urged him
to alter his approach
President Trump tried to pivot from all
the controversy surrounding China to
more favorable trade news including a
possible trade deal with Japan that
country to buy US corn and wheat that
deal would likely need congressional
approval something the president has not
been able to secure for his proposed
trade deal with Canada in Mexico Gale
Roy Paul a pivot see-sawing back and
forth a lot of confusion around this
topic so what do you think comes next
for the US and China in this trade
dispute well you're right Wall Street
will be watching amid all of this
confusion as talks continue between the
world's two largest economies look
they've been going on for months with no
sign of a deal in sight White House
officials tell CBS News they expect to
have another call with China later this
week and even in-person meetings in
Washington next month later today the
president will have a press conference
Yale is expected to be pressed on his
trade war knowing his answers and the
outcome will have enormous implications
for US markets and his chances of
reelection and we'll all be watching
Paula Reid reporting from France thank
you